auto box go
okay hm I exciting it up I shown you I
has a little tight little quinta copia
each of our exciting wow they're all
over the place you're gonna start an
attack on one enemy and then you're
going to change form and who I at the
next one the Transformers feel so at
home in their own skins in this game
they moved just as I always imagined
they would it just feels like
transformers that I played with as a kid
and the fact that platinum games is
achieve that is truly go to this kiddo
oh yeah buddy tell us i wanna meet up
with a no character de todo que eso no
character God ratito my robot or an Oni
Ichigo sect oh yah oh ok mochiron state
law school I donuts Cassie because you
know anime ok ok mr. my stick I'm also
no level totally no human nose tu con
doppio game yeah sorry Adam Eaton you
are so tofu c'mere you communicate no
one's haseeno digital Scott fit a post
call children's tables for you mamita
mayur puri Nazca she'd taste showing up
the mosquito more na kami battle no guru
ma ana margarita mucho que came down
study sweet a menorah non-committal hug
hi tomas of day
most logra [ __ ] odo otto action gave us
que NOS fuimos coconut Oh gusta marrero
naughty naughty little geomatics the
basic premise is the Decepticons have
come to earth and it appears that the
earth is actually changing in a violent
way into a new Cybertron so the Autobots
have come to figure out what's going on
to the Decepticons are step ahead of
them you play as the Autobots in an
effort to stop this terrible thing from
happening my whole gamut of our case of
story game challenging mission oil if
it's a symbol a voodoo mr. I got an REO
toy box
todo bien Mon on da 80 palanka your
heritage must Scout about a crime money
80 cara cara con tony his bond was
casting how to punish Ava somebody to
promote ago she hey Polly parrot Rock a
philosopher boubacar like
transformers devastation we must protect
our home no matter the cost